[Music]
all right let's uh let's get right to
the calls today let's go
out to tim in tucson arizona
tim what's going on this morning how are
you i'm good doctor josh how are you
outstanding brother so what's going on
how can i help
so in uh in march my nephew
took his life how old was he man
he was 21. i'm so sorry tim well i
i i really appreciate that um
and since then um my my oldest daughter
has really struggled with this one they
weren't necessarily close
however it's it's it's hit her in a way
that
it's kind of hard to to describe she is
kind of opened up about it and said you
know i i wish i could have done
something i wish i could have prevented
it
and then she then has continued to say
that you know i'm afraid
that possibly i will then take my life
sure
and then i don't know probably maybe a
month ago
she started having these night terrors
and it's been
four or five nights a week where she
just
wakes up with these terrible dreams of
you know him being hurt and she's trying
to save him and she can't
and it's it's just been relentless yikes
man
um and so we've we've
uh did i think that was this was going
to be
nice challenging your good brother's
hard man it's hard
yeah in my head i played this
conversation out multiple times and it
was way easier in my head
dude so much you should see when i try
to make a jump shot i'm always going to
make it in my head until i actually let
the ball go and it never
never goes in man so i'm with you hey
there is something and i appreciate you
saying that out loud
there's something uniquely um
um unique about saying something out
loud and it's hard so i appreciate you
doing that man that's brave brother
um so where does that leave you guys you
and your wife or does that leave your
family right now so
we have um you know we've reached out to
local counselors here okay and either
they don't take kids or
they're booked out for for months and
months
and or they don't accept our insurance
so it's only cash pay
yeah which i mean million dollars
yeah i mean and it's not about the money
it's just about the
um i just want to make sure she gets
some quality service so we actually
ended up reaching out to the school and
the counselor got in contact with her
and it was great and it was it was
it was working really well however with
summer approaching
yep that ends you know yeah and
i just i'm i'm at a point where i don't
know how i can
help my daughter because she doesn't
necessarily want to go to
another counselor and start over
you know with with trying to you know
progress
but i i'm trying to see if there's any
practical tools
you got it that me and my wife can do to
help her with these
these night terrors that she has man
well i love your heart dude
um yes there are and um there's also
um something you can do with it with the
counseling but
so give me one piece of information how
did she come to find out about this what
was what was your
you and your wife's grieving process
like how did your daughter find out
about it
walk me through that really quick so um
we got the phone call it was early in
the morning i don't know it's probably 5
30 in the morning
6 in the morning our time so we were
kids were up we were getting
you know ready for the day and so went
into the room
my brother told me hey you know um he he
actually didn't even tell me at first
that he had taken his life he said he
had passed away
um and so immediately me and my wife
were like well
let's let's see what we can do you know
if i could fly out there because he
lives in wisconsin
okay so that morning
was a little hectic i mean but we we
didn't really
we didn't divulge that information on to
them before going to school
you know we we needed a moment to be
able to kind of
try to process what happened you know
yep
and and what what our next steps were
and so we were as calm as we were we
could be with them i mean the kids could
tell something
was off because i was in the room sure
you know telling them hey stay out for
the time being
um so walk me to that afternoon or that
evening how'd y'all
tell them so i ended up
flying out that afternoon um and so
unfortunately my wife was kind of left
with the badge of kind of
explaining everything okay um and she
had said you know your cousin has passed
away
you know dad went out there to go be
with your uncle
and try to you know help in any way
possible
and immediately my daughter went to did
he kill himself
which right off the bat was like
holy cow we didn't even you know it was
out of the blue you know like why how
did how did your mind even come
to that um you know and so we were like
um well we're we're not going to lie to
you
you know we're he yes he he he
he did take his life and she wanted to
know why and how
how and we we were like you know we
don't we don't know how or why
at this point and does she know that
stuff yeah okay
um we we haven't we we didn't know
she he shot himself and so we don't
i i it's just such a i mean
but you haven't you haven't communicated
that to her right
no we have not i mean we i didn't ask
you how old is she
she's eleven okay all right um and so
go ahead please explain
you know there's there's you know the
the world is a hard place you know
and and sometimes people feel that's the
only way out
and in those situations we need to look
to
to help other people you know yeah and
you never you never know what
a comment you say could either make or
break someone else's day
and and it's it's it's it's super
fine light of i mean she's still
young but obviously you know this is
something
yeah yeah it's just such a hard place to
be in
you know yep all right so let's let's
back out of here a little bit
and here's what i'm to need you to
promise me okay
um i want you to promise me that um
i'm going to promise you i'm going to be
honest as i can with you with the best
of the information i got
and i want you to promise me that you
will
look that you will be joyful about
getting new information
and you're not going to walk back and
try to recreate or re do something that
you can't redo
is that cool right okay absolutely
awesome
so anytime i i can tell you story after
story after i was well trained in to
walk into these situations
i would come back and think man i
absolutely blew that and um i had a my
partner and i would debrief when i would
go into some of these situations and we
would both go in together and we would
talk about hey we should have said that
or you got to ask this question
differently and so
uh i want you to know trained people
still debrief and still say man i wish i
could say this again or that again all
that
so backing all the way up i
for an 11 year old i would err on the
side of
this statement when they ask how did it
happen
why did they do that saying things like
well some people just think that's their
way out some people just choose that
that's how they're going to do this
that is a destabilizing construct for an
11 year old
because the next question they're going
to ask themselves is well what if i'm
that kind of person
or what if i find myself in a situation
where that's the only result
um the only thing i can do so my
standard answer for adults and for
children is that they
they were not well they were really
struggling
they were sick there was a
illness in their heart and in their mind
and
they came to a heartbreaking conclusion
they they did something that they
weren't in their right mind
and that tends to alleviate this idea
that this is just going around it can
happen to anybody
and more oh okay
they were they were sick they were
struggling in that way also
when folks pressed me on details
i would often tell people i want the
last memory you have of that person
to be the last time you saw him smiling
saying goodbye
saying i love you saying i'll see you
later not with whatever imagination
imaginary media filled picture you're
going to concoct in your mind
of what that looks like because unless
you've seen that scene actually with
your own eyes
it's not what you think it is and so
i don't give details especially like
that to children
i might tell them when you get older we
can talk more in details but i want you
to remember
i want you to remember timmy or billy or
whatever his name is um i want you to
remember them
the last time we saw them they were
laughing and smiling before they got
sick
right and so i say things like they died
by suicide
not they committed suicide i want to
norm it that way
in the same way that a kid will be
terrified when somebody they know gets
and dies by cancer
or gets and dies by a heart attack
that's scary because their world
becomes a little bit less stable right
oh that just happens
uh people can get this thing and it and
it ends this way yes
and so i backing out of this even
another layer
is this idea that oh so let's pause here
so the conversation from this point
forward is
cousin died by suicide he was sick he
was really struggling
and this is not going to happen to you
um okay and you can say that with the
purity at the end of it
okay and what if i get sick what if i
get like this
we're always gonna be here so if you
ever feel like you're um
that you're not doing well or you're
struggling that's why we're here
and you're gonna reach out and we're
gonna create a space for you to reach
out
you're always okay to talk to us right
and so what you're trying to do is
trying to connect with your daughter not
trying to solve her pain hurt here
so then i want to back out one one more
circle if you will one more
one more i don't know another 10 000
feet here and recognize
that a common response to grief
especially
suicide or especially what people
imagine is a violent
end is their picture of that person gets
stuck
on the violence that they are still
hurting
right right and so a really remarkable
exercise that you as a family could do
together
um you and your wife and your 11 year
old
is to write a letter to him where he is
now
right and so if y'all are people of
faith that he's in heaven or if you're
not people of faith that
he is resting gently and he was sick and
he was really struggling
and now he's not hurting right
we wish he was here so much and writing
him a letter
talking about where he might be puts a
new picture in your daughter's head
whether that's in her imagination of
what heaven's gonna look like whether
he's
in a field but it begins to shift her
heart and mind away from this guy is
actively in gruesome pain right now
to oh he's not hurting anymore
we're hurting right and so she's
not stuck on that that night terror loop
of there is somebody in pain and i can
do nothing about
it my body is fighting and fleeing all
at the same time and it's waking me up
and waking me up and waking me up does
that make sense
so that makes sense gives her a new
picture for what that can look like
right
and so um the third thing would be
being really honest with her about mommy
and daddy are sad
and i want you to norm in your house
what those feelings are gonna be like
give her permission to if you will have
a release valve so maybe do a nightly
check-in
or not nightly because not doing it
around bedtime is good but an afternoon
check-in
were you thinking about billy today i
was it made me sad
i miss him how did you feel and give her
space give her an invitation to talk
some 11 year olds don't verbalize that
well so maybe draw on a picture
right giving her an opportunity or you
all just color together or something but
create 5 or 10 or 15 or 20 minutes a day
in the afternoon
or in the morning where y'all can have
some space together just to process out
loud
and let her see you grieving
and let her get a model of what grief
looks like that it's okay
i'm not bananas it's okay to hurt mommy
and daddy are sad too
and then recognize her entire world has
shattered
in that right people just die does that
make sense
it becomes existential too um and so
writing in that letter letting her
create a new picture and by the way in
that letter you can
she can say i'm really mad at you
that you did this she's allowed to say
that she can be mad at him
it can be heartbroken it can be
any number of feelings all those
feelings are okay getting them out on
paper gets them out of your head and
you can see them right and that comes
back to one last important thing that i
want to pass along
um man
you mentioned that um
some people just make this decision i
want you to be really
cautious about giving her weight you
never know if you just say the right
thing or the wrong thing
for an 11 year old every decision just
became life or death
every conversation yeah and so i don't
want an 11 year old walking around
bearing the weight of if i don't say
this thing right to whoever
they may die does that make sense
that that does and i get where your your
heart was awesome
your heart here's here's my other thing
i tell my son all the day all the time
you have the opportunity to shine a
light into somebody's day
every time you interact with them that
is a different weight
than you at any moment
you could say the wrong thing and
they're going to die right that's just
going to yeah
so one so i would shift that
conversation and maybe even say
hey i said this the wrong way you are
not going to ever be responsible for
somebody taking their life
11 year old child you're not you don't
have that kind of power
right if somebody chooses to take their
life they've got a whole bunch of other
stuff going
on if somebody else dies by suicide
there's
so much other things happening there
but what you can do is you can make
somebody feel loved
you can shine a light in somebody's soul
and so we in
our house we're gonna be about making
sure that the waitress
knows that we value her that that the
guy at burger king we love them
that that knucklehead who keeps driving
too slow in front of us
that we're gonna you know we're not
gonna yell at them and model for our
kids that we can't control our temper
that is a different way to shift that
conversation than than
tagging your kid does that make sense it
does and
and that's i mean over it has definitely
that conversation has shifted in that
direction
so what do we have go ahead go ahead no
no please i'll see
one last thing i would shift you uh our
shift to you is this about your teacher
ask your school counselor for an a
referral
in the city have you already done that
we have
um and we don't
live in tucson where we're like two
hours south so we're a smaller
community okay and it's they're just
there's not any options here it would it
would have to be going up
to tucson to try to find someone okay
and
she she did not know of anyone there so
let's do this we can have some fun
um you can turn it into a fun
conversation or a thing you're going to
do as a family
but i want you to go to
betterhelp.comramsie
and if you can't get in person they do
have online counseling they have a
special deal that we've they worked out
for listeners of
this show and um oh it's uh it's um
betterhelp.com and d-e-l-o-n-y
and they'll give you a discount and on
the first month
of counseling there but you and her
y'all could talk to a therapist
you can put it up on your tv screen at
home so she can watch it and be
interacting with it
and you can get some more practical
tools and tips there
but my hunch my gut tells me that you
guys sit down and have these
conversations with her
write him a letter have her imagine
where he is
now that he's not actively hurting
anymore um
have a nighttime routine talk about this
in the daytime not
right before bed so that that's the last
thing she's thinking about
begin to and then more most importantly
model for her what grieving looks like
what healthy grieving looks like
and of course if these night terrors
continue if she starts getting more
anxious you see
weight gain and weight loss you see her
beginning to become a shell of herself
um a hundred percent reach out do what
you got to do
you can do half day intensives there's
all kinds of different programs if you
gotta drive to a new city
start with betterhelp.com um but make
sure you are reaching out and
a high five to you guys for reaching out
to your school counselor that's
fantastic
um but try those things and then give me
a shout back let me know how those
things go
and i'm really grateful that you are
trying to do right by your daughter and
don't neglect your own grief here you
lost your nephew and that's heart
heartbreaking